It's great to see you church.
Uh, it is hard to express how much I love getting
to be one of your pastors.
Uh, your constant encouragement and love for me
and your hunger for the word
and hunger for worship, it spurs me on
and encourages me to keep going
and to keep getting better at what I do in my role.
So thank you for that.
Today though, we come to another really hard passage
of scripture and in very real and raw ways.
What we saw Nathan prophesy about David
and his family last week.
It, it only goes from bad to worse in these ways.
And, and honestly, there are some
really sensitive topics in these two chapters.
And so I wanna be cautious with this
and where we walk into this today.
I'm not trying to avoid what's in these chapters.
We clearly are just working through the book,
but I might skip reading some sections for a couple reasons.
First, because for you as parents, I want you to be able
to have those conversations with your kids on your timing
and your way, not just kind of lay it on
and then you have to deal with it.
Uh, but also secondly,
because I know that some of you in this room have
experienced horrific things similar
to what's in these chapters.
And so I wanna be really careful with that.
Wanna be cautious and not flippant about it
yet, I also wanna say that if that's you,
if you have experienced some things like that, what you went
through was wrong, and we want to be there
for you if we can, and care for you
and pray for you, find resources
for you if you would allow that for us.
And so in light of all that, I think we need to pray
before we get into God's word today.
So, Lord, this is your word, as hard
as it is often to read.
So I pray, Lord, that you just wash over this whole thing
with grace and mercy, meeting people in their time of need,
challenging us to flee sin,
to encouraging us to follow you,
to rest and lean on you, Lord, may this,
this passage today propel us even deeper towards
a trust in you, no matter the circumstance
and the chaos around us, no matter what happens to us,
no matter what we see in the world, no matter anything,
we trust you.
Help us towards that today as we look forward
to the day when there's no more pain, no more sorrow,
no more sin, no more death.
Come quickly, Lord Jesus, help us today. In Jesus' name.
Amen. So here's what we've seen so far
as we walk through Second Samuel.
We've, we've seen that David was a partial fulfillment
of the promise that God gave back in one Samuel
of this promised King.
One. Samuel set us up for it and,
and we saw Saul, uh, start with that process.
He failed at that. And then David was
anointed as the replacement.
And so here what we've seen is second Samuels.
You look at that chart, we've looked at most weeks, right?
This, this idea of second Samuel is David
rising to the throne.
And so far to this point, he seems
to have handled it all really well, God honoring kind
of ways until last week
in two Samuel 11 and 12,
and David's catalog of sins against Bathsheba,
against Uriah, against others.
But ultimately we saw his sin against God was
what set him and his family
and his nation on a downward trajectory.
Now, graciously, God still redeems.
God continues to work both in
and through David to bring about the Messiah a thousand
years later in God's sovereign plan through David's family,
but primarily strife
and trouble dominated David's family life and beyond.
And we'll see it very clearly
starting here in chapters 13 and 14 of two Samuel.
So here's how I want to go through this.
So I want to first just track the passages plot,
like find the narrative thread of what actually happened
as we walk through these two chapters.
So we just get the broad overview
of the story, the narrative.
Again, I'm not gonna read every word of these two chapters,
but I'm gonna give you enough to, to be able
to understand what's happening here.
And it starts in verse one of chapter 13.
Now, Absalom, David's son
had a beautiful sister whose name was Tamar.
And after a time, Amon, David's son loved her.
And so right off the bat, it gets weird right now, these,
these are half siblings.
Amon was David's son, oldest son from one of David's wives,
and then Absalom and Tamar were brother
and sister from another of David's wives.
And so there were sibling, half siblings,
all three from David.
That doesn't make it right,
but it does explain some of the rivalry that shows up
through these families.
Yet this was merely a symptom of a bigger problem.
It was evidence of the curse.
It it God put on David's family in a way
through Nathan's prophecy
that this was already showing up the family strife.
That's part of it. But there was more,
there was also this from back in Deuteronomy 1717 when God
originally gave the law to Israel.
He said, a couple hundred years from now,
you're going to want a king.
Here's how that king needs to be.
Listen to Deuteronomy 17, 17.
God says, he the king shall not acquire many wives
for himself, lest his heart turn away,
nor shall he acquire for himself excessive silver and gold.
Yet what did David do
and what did many, most of the kings following him do?
Well, partly due to lust
and partly due to political maneuvering.
They were just trying to make their,
their status in the world better.
They wrongly gained many wives.
But just think about the environment that that created.
It would create power plays, it would create family strife.
It was an environment in which the prophecy Nathan said
would come true of David's family.
That's the environment.
It would happen in just family
dynamics to an extreme.
And here in two Samuel 13, it began to play out that way.
Now it said that Amon loved Tamar.
It was not true love.
I would more classify it as lust,
where he made himself physically sick
because he loved Tamar so much,
he desired her so much.
Well, what happens throughout the rest of the chapter is
that he would scheme away
to get her to come to him.
He acted as sick.
He made himself, uh, kind of a bed in his room
and he invited through David Tamar
to come make him some food to make him feel better.
Unwittingly, David participates in this.
He doesn't know anything's going on.
And so he says, okay, Tamar, you go to Amon.
And as she came into his private bedroom,
Amon violated Tamar.
And I want you just to think the generational echo
is deafening here.
Does it not sound parallel to
what David just did a couple chapters ago?
And of course, Tamar is grieved beyond words over
what has just happened.
And so she runs to her brother Absalom's house,
who protects her, provides for her,
and begins to breed this hatred towards am
not for what he'd done.
But what did David do?
Well, look down at verse 21.
All this has happened. Watch what happens.
Verse 21, when King David heard of all these things,
he was very angry.
That's it. Like that, that's all it says.
Some manuscripts add, maybe a little questionable,
but they add something like he was, he was loving Amon
as his oldest more than anyone else.
Whatever it was, we don't know either way.
He didn't do anything. He didn't do anything about this.
Now, was it because he knew that if he would judge Amon for
what Amon had just done, that he would condemn himself for
what he had just done with Bathsheba possibly.
So he just kind of abdicates any responsibility as a father,
and he just says, ah, no,
I'm not gonna do anything either way.
Tragedy had struck David's family
and we, we rejoice Psalm 51, we saw last week
that God forgave David's sin against heaven,
but God did not remove sins.
Earthly shadow from David's family.
This is what we experience here in this passage.
Well watch what happens next.
It only goes from bad to worse.
Verse 23,
after two full years, Absalom had sheep shears at Baal Hazo,
which is near Ephraim.
And Absalom invited all the king sons.
And Absalom came to the king
and said, behold, your servant has sheep shears.
Please let me please let the king
and his servants go with your servant.
But the king said to Absalom, no, my son,
let us not all go lest we be burdensome to you.
So Absalom pressed him, but he would not go,
but gave him his blessing.
And Absalom said, if not, please let my brother,
brother Amon go with us.
And the king said to him, why should he go with you?
But Absalom pressed him until he let Amon
and all the king's sons go with him.
Then Absalom commanded his servants, mark,
when Amons heart is Mer with wine.
And when I say to you, strike Amon, then kill him.
Do not fear have I not commanded you?
Be courageous, be valiant.
And so the servants of Absalom did to Amon
as Absalom had commanded, then all the king's sons arose
and each mounted his mule and fled.
So see what just happened after two full years
where Absalom was nursing his hatred like Gollum
with the ring, he's, he's just nursing this hatred.
And then he plays the gracious host.
Yet the whole time he's plotting his revenge against Amon.
And notice, just like David did with Uriah,
Absalom had his servants do the dirty work.
I don't wanna touch him, but you guys go kill
him again.
Nathan's prophecy to David was coming true.
Remember Nathan said the sword will not
depart from your house.
What's happening? Death, destruction,
it's all over the place.
It's sibling rivalry to the extreme.
And so this has happened, and now the rest
of David's family returns to Jerusalem
and they're grieving together because of what just happened.
But Absalom instead, he flees to his grandpa's house
that's in a different part of the region
and he ends up staying there for three years.
He might've thought as he was taking Amons life,
he he might've thought, man, I'm gonna honor Tamar
because of what he did to her.
But what he did is instead just multiplies her grief
because now in a sense she's lost another brother, the one
who was protecting her, providing for her, he's gone.
And so she's alone
then think about am Absalom's life.
He's in exile from his homeland.
He's living this different style
of life than he was in Jerusalem.
And he, you can think how empty he must feel as he's fleeing
and really a, a fear of his life really.
So that takes us to chapter 14, Where
as we move into this chapter,
you might remember Joab Joab was, uh, the leader
of David's army.
He was very loyal to David.
And what we find in chapter 14 is actually similar to
what Nathan did with David in chapter 12.
What Joab does is he brings this woman before David
and he is telling her a story to tell to David, to try
to get David to do something
that Joab thinks David would want to do.
He would assume David wants to reconcile
with Absalom, his son.
And so Joab iss like, I'm gonna work this situation
to make sure that David brings Absalom home.
And this woman tells the story to David.
But David has been duped before by a story.
And so he sees through it this time, but it still works.
It still works to bring Absalom back to Jerusalem.
Here's what Joab didn't understand, though.
He didn't know that David is not like the,
the father in the Luke 15 prodigal son parable.
The son comes home, the the father runs to him
and embraces him and welcomes him back in.
Joab thought that's how David's gonna be. David is not that
Way.
He did not run out to greet Absalom when he returned.
In fact, he refused to meet with Absalom, his own son.
Joab set the table like this is gonna happen.
Reconciliation between father and son.
That's how it's gonna work, right? This is great.
And David doesn't, now
the the narrator.
So, so this is, this is written
by someone looking back at the story.
They're hearing all the accounts
and they're, they're writing it down.
The narrator inserts something really interesting here in
the middle of this narrative.
He describes Absalom in certain
ways, could just tell the story.
He came back to Jerusalem, here's what happened.
But, but then there's this insertion of
of a picture of Absalom.
And I want you to see this.
Look at verses 25 and 26 of chapter 14.
And this is really important
because there's some foreshadowing here about
what will happen over the next few weeks.
Two Samuel 14 verses 25 and 26.
See this Now in all Israel, there was no one so much
to be praised for his handsome appearance as Absalom
from the sole of his foot to the crown of his head.
There was no blemish in him.
And when he cut the hair of his head for at the end
of every year, he used to cut it.
When it was heavy on him, he would cut it.
He weighed the hair of his head, 200 shekels
by the king's weight.
That's five pounds of hair
Like Pantene commercial to the max right here, right?
But why does this inserted into the story seems irrelevant.
That's what he looked like. His hair
was beautiful, all these things.
It will show up again over the next few chapters.
And it's a bit of foreshadowing
because doesn't it sound, just think about this,
doesn't it sound a whole lot like the way Saul was
described back in First Samuel?
Remember Saul was a head taller than everybody else.
He looks the part, he's handsome.
He's, he's surely the king, right?
That guy, he looks like he's gonna be the king.
Certainly he is the king
and he was the king for a while.
But what we learned about Saul is
what we'll learn about Absalom here we came to discover
that Saul's heart was not right.
His, his posture and his body looked the part,
but his heart was wrong.
Absalom looks the part, but his heart was wrong as well.
Watch what happens. Verse 28.
So Absalom lived two full years in Jerusalem without coming
into the King's presence.
Then Absalom sent for Joab to send him to the king,
but Joab would not come to him.
And he sent a second time, but Joab would not come.
Then he said to his servants,
see Jo Abs field is next to mine.
He has barley there. Go and set it on fire.
So Absalom servants set the field on fire.
Then Jo AB arose, went to Absalom at his house
and said to him, why have your servants
set my field on fire?
Absalom answered, Joab, behold, I sent word to you,
come here that I may send you to the king
to ask why have I come from Yeshua?
It'd be better for me to be there still now,
therefore, let me go into the presence of the king
and if there's guilt in me, let him put me to death.
And then Joab went to the king, told him,
and he summoned Absalom, and he came to the king
and bowed himself on his face to the ground before the king
and the king kissed Absalom.
Now that got ugly real quick, didn't it?
I can realize why Absalom was frustrated,
but to the point where you start burning people's fields
because of it like that,
that just indicates something's wrong in his own heart,
which is all evidence of God's judgment
on this family for what David had done.
But I want you to notice what happened here at the end,
how the narrative ended.
Absalom finally sees David two years
after his return to Jerusalem, which was three years
after Amman's murder.
So for five whole years, David
and Abson never even saw each other once,
and we don't even know yet.
'cause the way it reads at the end is very vague.
We don't even know yet if they're going to be reconciled
because to this point, neither father
nor son had repented of their actions.
We don't see it in David, we don't see it in Absalom.
They're just both kind of living
and now they're face to face
and we don't know how it's going to go.
But think about that. They were both in
Jerusalem for two whole years.
They were living under the same sky,
but they were worlds apart.
There was proximity without presence.
There was relationship without reconciliation.
If you've ever lived in that state with someone,
it is incredibly difficult, isn't it?
It's sad if these are father's son
and they live near each other,
but they're not even gonna talk to each other.
It's very sad end
and we'll see it only get worse
over the next couple chapters.
But that's the plot. So that's chapter 13 and 14.
What then are the lessons we need to learn from this?
As tragic as this is,
what do we learn from it about the characters,
about ourselves, about humanity?
What do we learn about God? What lessons should we learn?
Here's three lessons.
The first one, sin always over promises,
but under delivers.
As we look at these two chapters, sin always over promises
and under delivers.
Amon was obsessed with Tamar.
That poisonous root of lust went unchecked in his life
and it led to this kind of sinful
and destructive behavior like father-like son, right?
But I want you to notice something here at the beginning
of chapter 13, Amon supposedly loved Tamar.
Again, that was just lust,
but that sin the temptation, it overpromised,
but underdelivered, watch this.
Here's how that sin overpromised and underdelivered.
You can imagine the temptation coming into amman's heart
as the enemy would toss things in his mind.
He's like, Hey, hey, listen, Amon,
God's holding out on you, man.
There's no reason you can't have her.
Why is God holding out on you? Look at how beautiful she is.
Surely you'll be fulfilled once you have her.
You should go take her It over.
Promise it promised a lot,
but watch how it under delivered.
Look back at chapter 13, verse 15.
Then like this is immediately
after he had done what he had done to her immediately.
Then Amon hated her with very great hatred.
So that the hatred with which he hated her was greater than
the love with which he had loved her.
And Amon said to her, get up. Go.
Like immediately, his mindset toward her flipped
what he thought he was gonna get out of it.
He actually got the exact opposite from it.
Why? Because it wasn't love to begin with.
Listen, if it's lust, if you're driven by lust,
it's gonna be take, take, take.
And then if something doesn't give you what you want,
it's not going to fulfill you.
It's gonna actually flip on you. Lust is take, take.
But if it's love, if you're driven by love, it's give,
give, give.
The supposed pleasure
that he sought lasted mere moments.
But the destruction and devastation lasted a lifetime.
Sin always over promises and under delivers.
How have you seen that in your life, right?
Have you seen this, this false promise
of fulfillment show up where this,
this thing you thought would bring you joy that you crave,
but it ended up actually making your life worse.
Like that time you thought winning
that argument would validate you,
but now you just kind of feel hollow
and there's this atmosphere of of bitterness
around you from other people too.
Or you materialistically thought that
that nicer car would bring you the self-confidence
that you want,
but that same insecurity creeps in
as the new car smell fades.
Or you thought that that one more drink or one more scroll
or one more episode, will finally relax you
until you overdo it
and then you end up being more depleted than
before and on and on, right?
There's all kinds of things. But all of those, all
of those start with sin promising something.
You wouldn't do it if it wasn't like, Hey,
there's something on the other side of this, right?
Sin promises something, whether it's fulfillment or joy
or peace or pleasure
or whatever, like it promises something.
Yet the moment you let those seeds begin to grow,
it always under delivers.
It promises and then it under delivers.
And so what do we, what should we do with this?
We should cut sin off at the root.
We shouldn't even let the desires fester.
This promise start to creep in.
Like maybe I'm, maybe, God, you are holding out on me.
That sounds like Genesis in the garden, right?
Genesis three, God's holding out on you.
God's got more for you. He's not telling you about,
that's the desire of our sinful flesh, festering.
We should cut that off at the root
because here's what the enemy will do.
He will tell you lie to you.
It won't get that bad. You, you.
You can control it like you can.
You can dabble in this just a little bit.
You can do this just a little bit,
but you'll be able to keep it under control.
You'll be able to keep it managed.
You don't have to worry about,
it's not gonna get outta control.
He's lying to you. He's overpromising something.
And the under delivery of that is
that it gets way outta control.
Far worse than you could ever imagine.
You never would've thought at the beginning this one little
step would lead to that.
That's why like John Owen said hundreds of years ago,
you must be killing sin or it will be killing you.
Sin always over promises and under delivers.
So flee from it instead of pursue it.
Here's the second lesson.
It's very specific example of what I just talked about.
Revenge promises justice,
but delivers emptiness.
Revenge promises justice, but it delivers emptiness.
Did Amon deserve to die for what he did to Tamar? Yes.
But was Absalom the one who was supposed to take
that justice only if
God clearly told him to do it?
And we don't see that anywhere.
We Don't see God approve of what Absalom did here.
Instead, what we discover is a two year scheme
to take Amons life.
Now, God did bring justice on Amon through this.
Sinful means. God still brought about justice for Amon,
but Absalom was not innocent.
His guilt started in the long game of bitterness
that he played in the
garden of his heart.
He was actively cultivating amman's destruction.
And look at what it brought Absalom.
It brought this emptiness.
It brought estrangement from his family for five years
when it could have been handled completely differently.
You may have heard the phrase,
revenge is a dish best served
cold for the Christian.
You ought to send that dish right back to the kitchen.
Remember what Romans 1219 said?
Vengeance is mind says the Lord. That means it's not ours.
We're gonna do it wrongly.
We're gonna go after something
and we're gonna say, this is justice.
This is the right thing and we're gonna mess it up.
But God never will. God will always bring perfect justice,
perfect vengeance in his time, in his way.
We don't see the whole picture. We don't know what's best.
How is this actually gonna bring the most glory to God?
How's this actually gonna be good for everyone else?
And we just go for it and we cause more destruction.
That's why Jesus said, love your enemies,
because it's God's job, not ours,
to bring justice in the end.
That means there's mechanisms,
God's set up, governments, that kind of stuff.
Yes. But for us personally, our job is not to take
vengeance because it only leads to emptiness.
It only leads to things
that cause more pain and sorrow.
So let him bring about the judgment on sin that he desires.
All of this leads us to the third lesson we ought
to get from this passage and
to see this one we've gotta put on our hermeneutical lenses
of Christological focus.
See, hermeneutics is just the study of
how we understand God's word, how we interpret the,
the passages of scripture and how they all work together.
We have to put on those specific lenses
to look back into the Old Testament, to see Jesus there.
So Luke 24 shows us.
Jesus showed us that we can see Him everywhere.
How do we see Jesus here?
How do we see with the lenses of Christ
that he is the promised king?
Well, here's the third lesson where David's sons failed.
David's son succeeded.
Where David's sons failed.
Notice the capital S that's talking
to the title, the Son of David.
'cause remember back in chapter seven, God told David, one
of your sons will sit on the throne forever.
So we got a couple options here, couple sons.
Let's see how they showed up here.
So I'll show you how we see Jesus through all this.
The true promise king who fulfilled all of this.
Let me show you how Jesus is the son
that they were talking about.
Not these guys. Think about Amon.
Amon nurtured lust and selfishness in his heart.
Jesus starved it.
I've said this before, Hebrews four 15,
For we do not have a high priest who's unable to sympathize
with our weaknesses, but one
who in every respect has been tempted as we are
yet without sin.
David failed at that. Amon failed at that.
But Jesus in the wilderness faced the core temptations every
one of us will ever face.
And he overcame it, not by his own willpower, but
because he trusted the spirit of God
and the word of God to defeat the enemy.
And he never gave in his entire life,
never sinned once He is the promised
son of David.
Think of Absalom another option.
Absalom calculated murder.
Jesus calculated mercy.
Instead of executing revenge, Jesus
absorbed it on the cross.
Instead of calling down hundreds of angels
to execute his tormentors
and to destroy them, Jesus took the justice
that we deserve
and gave us the forgiveness that we could never earn.
He didn't take revenge.
He absorbed it so that you and I could be free.
He's the promised son of David.
David himself failed unreconciled relationship with Absalom,
poor fathering all over the place,
but they were separated for two years in the same vicinity
for five years total instead of allowing us
to remain separated from God.
Ephesians two 16, Jesus reconciles us
to God in one body through the cross, killing the hostility.
He became our peace destroying the wall of hostility
between us and God.
He said, I'm not gonna leave you separated.
I'm bringing you to myself.
He's the promised son of David
where David's sons failed.
The son of David succeeded and he is our hope.
And so church, these chapters we've studied today
are both a mirror and a warning.
Will we be like Amon feeding our lusts until they devour us?
Will we be like Absalom nursing our
wounds until they poison us?
Will we be like David not reconciling with those around us?
Or will we be
living out this rest in God's power
to kill sin at the root, to love our enemies, to pray
for those who persecute us
and to pursue reconciliation with others?
Which one are we gonna be? Which one are we gonna pursue?
That's the mirror we have here.
And the warning is that if we walk that path, it's going
to destroy and damage and harm.
See, here's the thing. The gospel is not just
that our sins are forgiven, given
the gospel includes the fact that we are wholeheartedly
transformed by the very spirit of God.
Something that happens as we look to Jesus, the author
and perfecter of our faith, who for the joy set
before him despised the shame of the cross
and took it upon himself.
Why? So that we might be free.
That's the heart cry.
The the growing love for him is because we see him in that.
We see him right here in chapter 13 and 14.
How will we respond? Well, that's the question I want us
to ask right now as you bow your heads with me,
just to focus a little bit here.
And I wanna ask you to do what that just said to do.
Take this as a mirror. Take this as a warning.
Will we be like these in the passages?
And maybe even ask yourself, how have you been like that?
How have you
he believed the over promises that sin offers?
Where are you right now pursuing something that is
outside the bounds of God's commands?
It will not satisfy you. His commands are not to burden you.
These commands are to give you life in Christ
that life is designed this way.
When you live that way, it works better.
But in that run to his power, you can't do that yourself.
So where are you running away? Down a path that's not godly.
Run back to him, turn back to him. Repent.
Maybe it's revenge, maybe it's lust. Maybe it's greed.
Maybe it's pride.
And maybe you've been hurt,
harmed in some way by someone else.
You. You also carry that to the cross run to Jesus in that
to say, Jesus, you are the justice seeker.
You are the the judge of all.
You are the one who's gonna make this right in your time
and your way, and leave it there, rest in him,
but look to him as the promised
king maybe for the first time.
Maybe you're not ever,
maybe you've been in church your whole life
and you've never seen Jesus as this kind
of king, run to him.
Own your sin. Say you need a savior. Jesus, I trust you.
He will transform your life. Lord, help us.
We need you every hour.
We need you and things like
this in your word.
Remind us that we need you left to our own.
We will destroy ourselves and others. God, we need you.
Help us now. In Jesus' name. Amen.
Let's stand together and let's respond and worship.